él tiene 30 años hoy en la escuela
Polytechnique de Montréal 14 mujeres tienen
fueron asesinados en un atentado contra
feminista 30 años y luego Geneviève
Helene Colgan Bergeron Nathalie Croteau
y Barbara Daigneault fueron asesinados
sangre fría
treinta años de la vida de ana
marie edward maud haviernick maryse
laganiere marie-jo leclerc y anne marie
lemay terminó en el
circunstancias más trágicas 30 años
desde que perdimos a sonia peletier
michel richard dany st-arnaud
Annie Turcotte y Barbara Klatch Nick
vertedero de perra nos reunimos
hoy para llorar la pérdida de estos
esposas de sus hijas de sus hermanas sus
amigos de sus colegas
[Música]